♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WE DON'T ENDORSE A
LOT OF CANDIDATES ON THE SHOW OR
GET EVEN TOO CLOSE TO
POLITICIANS BECAUSE HONESTLY
MOST OF THEM ARE REALLY
DISAPPOINTING, THEY SAY THEY ARE
GOING TO THE ONE THING BUT TO
ANOTHER.
BUT OCCASIONALLY WE RUN INTO
SOMEBODY WHO COULD ACTUALLY
CHANGE THINGS AND YOU KNOW THAT
PERSON CAN CHANGE THINGS BECAUSE
ALL THE RIGHT PEOPLE ARE
HYSTERICAL, LITERALLY
HYSTERICAL, ABOUT THE IDEA OF
HIM ADVANCING TO THE UNITED
STATE SENATE.
THAT WOULD BE J.D. VANCE, AND
HE'S RUNNING FOR SENATE FROM
OHIO.
THE PRIMARY IS TOMORROW WE
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE NICE TO TALK
TO HIM ON THE EVE OF THAT.
THANKS A LOT FOR COMING ON
TONIGHT.
CONGRATS ON THE POLL NUMBERS
SHOWING YOU AHEAD, BUT I STILL
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE WORTH
HEARING YOU EXPLAIN WHY YOU WANT
TO BE IN THE SENATE, WHAT WOULD
YOU DO IF YOU GET THERE?
>> WELL, SIMPLY I WOULD FIGHT
FOR NORMAL PEOPLE BECAUSE I
THINK FOR SO LONG THERE WERE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, WHICH SENT
PEOPLE THAT REPRESENTED THE
DONORS ARE THE OTHER SPECIAL
INTERESTS IN OUR COUNTRIES,
CORPORATE CLASS FOR EXAMPLE
FORCING PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES
TO GIVE HORMONAL THERAPIES TO
CHILDREN.
THOSE PEOPLE HAVE A VOICE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., BUT NORMAL
PEOPLE DON'T.
AND IF I COULD SAY, TUCKER, I
THINK THE MISTAKE IN THIS
ELECTION, THIS PRIMARY IN
PARTICULAR IS WHAT KIND OF A
REPUBLICAN PARTY WILL WE HAVE.
WILL WE HAVE THE OLDER
REPUBLICAN PARTY THAT STARTED
STUPID FOREIGN WARS, THAT
SHIPPED AMERICAN MANUFACTURING
BASES TO CHINA, AND I DIDN'T
ACTUALLY DEFEND AMERICA'S
CULTURAL VALUES?
OR ARE WE GOING TO HAVE A
REPUBLICAN PARTY THAT FIGHTS FOR
OUR OWN VOTERS, PROTECTS THE
JOBS OF THE AMERICAN
MANUFACTURERS AND MANUFACTURING
SECTOR AND THAT FIGHT BACK
AGAINST THESE STUPID FOREIGN
BUSINESS VENTURES?
THAT'S REALLY WHAT'S ON THE
TABLE, I FEEL CONFIDENT OHIO
VOTERS ARE GOING TO CHOOSE
BECAUSE OF THE END OF THE DAY
THEY DON'T WANT TO GO BACKWARDS,
THEY WANT A REPUBLICAN PARTY
THAT ACTUALLY STANDS FOR
AMERICANS FIRST.
>> Tucker: I DON'T EVEN NEED
TO HEAR WORD OF YOUR PITCH TO
KNOW YOU'RE THE GUY, BECAUSE I
KNOW FOR A FACT THERE ARE A LOT
OF REPUBLICAN SENATORS IN
WASHINGTON WERE TERRIFIED BY THE
IDEA OF YOU GETTING THERE.
ARE YOU AWARE OF THAT?
>> I'M CERTAINLY AWARE OF IT.
IN FACT, IF YOU LIVE IN OHIO
YOU'VE SEEN $20 MILLION, CLOSE
TO THAT, OF NEGATIVE
ADVERTISING, ALMOST ALL OF IT
FOCUSED AGAINST ME.
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH, THE SAME
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE TRYING TO
TAKE ME DOWN IN 2022 ARE THE
SAME GROUPS THAT TRIED TO TAKE
TRUMP DOWN IN 2016.
IT'S ACTUALLY THE EXACT SAME
PRO-CHINA, ANTI-AMERICAN
ORGANIZATIONS.
SO I'M CERTAINLY AWARE OF IT BUT
THESE ARE THE FIGHTS THAT ARE
WORTH HAVING.
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE PROFITED
FROM THE MANAGED DECLINE OF THIS
COUNTRY, THEY ARE KNUCKLING TO
GIVE UP THEIR POWER AND THEIR
MONEY EASILY BUT THESE ARE THE
FIGHTS THAT ARE ULTIMATELY WORTH
HAVING.
THE FACT THAT THEY ARE COMING
AFTER ME LET ME KNOW I'M DOING
SOMETHING RIGHT AND HOPEFULLY
THE PEOPLE OF OHIO SEE THAT I'M
DOING SOMETHING RIGHT AS WELL.
>> Tucker: THEY CAN TELL
YOU'RE SINCERE AND ARE VER